se abrazaban en salud restaurada
mitsubishi más de soldados
gracias
desde el punto de vista occidental en
hai el gorbachov pasó a la historia como
una de las figuras más importantes de la
política internacional por ser uno de
los artífices del final de la guerra
fría y también del fin de la atención
nuclear latente entre eeuu y la entonces
unión soviética
pero en su país en rusia es visto como
el causante de la disolución de la unión
soviética y también de la crisis
económica y política que vino tras el
colapso de la unión sin importar del
lado desde donde se le mire lo cierto es
que imagino un mundo completamente
diferente al que le tocó vivir o por lo
menos al mundo que le tocó gobernar
planteó reformas y la necesidad de un
cambio para su país la unión soviética
para que éste siguiera siendo una
potencia competitiva en un mundo que
cada vez estaba más interconectado y se
abría cada vez más y donde los valores
de los individuos cobraban mucho más
peso veamos algunos datos importantes
algunos datos destacados mijail
gorbachov nació en 1931 en una familia
campesina y llegó a la cima de la unión
soviética y desde allí presenció su
colapso y la desaparición llegó al poder
en
1985 e inició un diálogo sin precedentes
con eeuu y firmó también un tratado
bilateral para reducir las armas
nucleares entre estos dos países
representó una nueva era para el partido
comunista en la unión soviética y
propuso reformas y también cambios tanto
en asuntos internos como externos en
1988 retiro las tropas soviéticas de
afganistán
en 1990 recibió el premio nobel de paz
por el cambio que instó en las
relaciones entre occidente y la unión
soviética en agosto de 1991 gorbachov
resistió un intento de golpe de estado
por parte de los más conservadores del
gobierno bajo presión dimitió del cargo
y la unión soviética desapareció dando
origen a 15 repúblicas independientes
intentó poner en marcha la economía
soviética estancada y poco modernizada
en diferentes aspectos para ellos
gorbachov propuso una combinación de
reestructuración y transparencia unos
conceptos muy conocidos como glasnost y
perestroika
que son dos palabras que eternamente van
a estar ligadas a mijail gorbachov de
qué se trata pues lo vamos a ver
entonces en el siguiente informe que
espero perestroika y glasnost
mijail gorbachov pasará a la historia
por su intento de reformar la unión
soviética cuando este mandatario llegó
al poder en 1985 como secretario en
general del partido comunista se
encontró una nación estancada por
décadas de inmovilismo y emprendió una
serie de reformas que cambiarían el
destino de su país para siempre aunque
no de la forma que él esperaba sus
pilares de cambio fueron la perestroika
una reforma que pretendía traer
aperturismo económico y el glasnost que
abriría políticamente a la urss
necesitamos más emprendimiento más
democracia más organización y disciplina
entonces podremos llevar a la
perestroika a toda velocidad y dar un
nuevo impulso al desarrollo del
socialismo socialismo gorbachov se había
mostrado muy crítico con los errores
cometidos por la urss desde la época de
stalin pero no pretendía acabar con el
socialismo sus reformas simplemente
querían terminar con décadas de
corrupción permitir el libre mercado o
no perseguir a otras corrientes
ideológicas pero no resultaron como se
esperaba esta nación no estaba preparada
para la dura al mercado tras décadas de
economía planificada lo que llevó al
país a una profunda crisis además la
libertad política trajo la crítica al
partido comunista una tensión que
degeneró en que tanto comunistas
ortodoxos como pro occidentales
rechazarán a gorbachov que sufrió un
gran desgaste hasta quedar totalmente
desacreditado algo que lo llevó a
renunciar a la presidencia en 1991 sí sí
sí
en esta situación que sigue el
establecimiento de la comunidad de
estados independientes de sudar se dejó
de actuar como presidente de la unión
soviética un apuesto presidente eso es
raro esta dimisión también supuso el
final de la unión soviética que termino
desintegrada en 15 nuevos estados
porque el legado de mijail gorbachov
genera tantas discrepancias está rusia
la rusia actual lista para entender su
legado con todas sus luces y sus sombras
en la rusia actual
cerca de esa rusia que ideó gorbachov
con sus reformas y la trans
transparencia su error fue tal vez
fortalecer el papel del individuo del
ciudadano soviético por encima del poder
del estado soviético como lo va a
recordar occidente hoy en el debate de
france 24 mijail gorbachov héroe o
traidor es nuestro tema de análisis y
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a manolo gonzález moscote él es
analista político internacional también
es periodista fue durante muchos años
corresponsal internacional de la ciudad
de moscú tuvo la oportunidad de
entrevistar diferentes oportunidades a
mijail gorbachov también les recuerdo
que ustedes hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y comentarios a través de las
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde no se
encuentran como france24 y un bajo es a
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta para que dejen sus comentarios
es numeral el debate efe 24 en youtube
también pueden seguir nuestra señal en
streaming y pueden participar en el chat
en vivo y también aprovecho para saludar
a las personas que nos están escuchando
a través del podcast todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa ya están
disponibles en diferentes plataformas
ustedes no se encuentran en app el
podcast en spotify deezer y en tuning
pues le doy la bienvenida entonces a
manolo gracias por estar con nosotros
manolo un gusto tenerlo con nosotros en
el programa y punto de partida como me
gusta llamar a la primera pregunta para
conocer las posiciones de nuestros
invitados el panorama general pregunta
obligada en este tipo de casos manolo el
legado lo positivo y lo negativo que de
joven hailee gorbachov para la historia
del siglo 20
de santiago gracias por la bueno básica
rítmica y el duro hecho le deja un gran
legado cuál es el legado de la humanidad
dos palabras claves en que siempre
mencionó en todo escenario y se llaman
libertad y democracia dos palabras que
hoy rusia no tiene no cuenta y que putin
prácticamente ha enterrado como parte de
enterrar también el legado de mijail
gorbachov de hacer la paz con occidente
de llevarse micro occidente y obviamente
esto pondría en buenos patines en buenas
ruedas argucia con el mundo cosa que hoy
no está sucediendo por todo lo que todos
conocemos lo que ha hecho vladimir putin
lo cierto es que mijail gorbachov tuvo
la gran oportunidad de hacer un nuevo
país que no lo alcanzo a lograr cuál era
el nuevo país pretendía quería una unión
soviética con un nuevo matiz con el
matiz como tú inicialmente lo anunciaba
esto de la gente por encima del estado y
demás quería una unión soviética no
comunista y socialista porque eso no
existe ni ha existido nunca existen
franquicias que utilizan el socialismo
el común y a disfrazar es a esas
magistrales extraordinarias y loquísimas
dictaduras que hay por todo el mundo lo
cierto es que él quería un país tipo
unión la unión europea cee ese tipo de
convenios entre los países entre las 15
repúblicas que sean parte de la unión
soviética pero bueno las cosas no se
dieron santiago porque la gente entendió
otra cosa que era mejor la oportunidad
de separarse cada una de la república
su camino que era lo que realmente
todos pretendían y querían cuando el
esbozo en el pleno del partido comunista
en abril del año 85 esto de la
perestroika clara eso de que vas a
cambiar y la grados transparencia para
que todo el mundo local e internos
perdiera lo que estaba pasando dentro
del país y tú se dice en confianza en
los rusos o bien sea que te digo hoy ya
no existe
bueno lo usted mencionados conceptos
como parte de este legado y es en la
libertad y la democracia esto no era
completamente opuesto a lo que tenía la
unión soviética como
a propósito a nivel político
precisamente uno de los temas que le
criticaban a la unión soviética era la
falta de libertades para los ciudadanos
y fuera de eso la ausencia de procesos
democráticos aunque hay que decir que
los ciudadanos soviéticos participaron
en unos referendos o en unas consultas
precisamente para expresar su su opinión
sobre permanecer o no dentro de la unión
soviética y esto pues se puede
considerar como un proceso democrático
pero esto iba completamente en contra de
lo que se veía de la unión soviética él
chocaba con el sistema
bueno mira el poder bastante curioso
mijail gorbachov desde el año 78 fue
perfilado fue utilizado y fue enseñado
porque debieron entrar a inter me dieron
la calidad humana que tenía la facilidad
de entendimiento y que con él podrían
tener una punta de lanza hacia occidente
para negociar pues bueno desde el 78
comenzó a viajar le comenzaron a enviar
de viaje y comenzó a ver cómo era
occidente y como realmente era distinto
a la propaganda que se vivía en la unión
soviética todavía en ese momento verdad
y ahí es donde él aprende y se da cuenta
de que la unión soviética tiene un
proceso retarda trishna probé la retarda
trace mientras que occidente lleva una
rueda de progreso y desarrollo muy
adelantada frente a lo que él vivía y
tenía en audio soviética y lo que él
pensaba que era el mundo porque lo que
pase en este país en estos tipos de
dictadura cuando la gente no sabe no
conoce piensa que lo que estás viendo
internamente es lo mejor que hay para
elegir verdad bueno mi cálculo hecho
supo hacer la elección cuando él llega
después de todos estos viajes inglaterra
la europa del este del oeste se da
cuenta de que hay falencias muy graves
de que el sistema no funciona de que la
unión soviética es todo un sistema
anticuado absolutamente de todo y es
cuando piensa en estas grandes reformas
y de estos grandes cambios fíjate lo
mandaron para que aprendiera más y fuera
y pudiera enfrentar a occidente y
terminó precisamente entendiendo que
como en occidente se vivían tenían que
vivir también los soviéticos así y es
cuando el
35 comunista esbozar su plan pero te
repito todo esto se le salió de la mano
sea y se le salió la unión soviética de
la fama no alcanzo a hacer que
entendieran que lo que él buscaba y
pretendía era el bienestar general esto
yo en contraposición como tú dices de
todos los lineamientos la unión
soviética una dictadura la unión
soviética no había libertades todavía
partidos no había ninguna clase de
democracia la nomenclatura que tú tengas
que elegir o elegir al candidato que te
ponían seguro debía sobre absolutamente
de ninguna racismo
manolo le invito para que hagamos una
pequeña pausa y vamos a la bienvenida a
claudio iger flow él se encuentra en la
ciudad de buenos aires sp es
especialista en historia política y
social rusa también el director de la
licenciatura en historia y de la
maestría en historia conceptual de la
universidad nacional san martín él se
encuentra en la ciudad de buenos aires y
se conecta desde la capital argentina
para incorporarse a esta a este análisis
a esta conversación
claudia gracias por estar con nosotros
gracias por acompañarnos en el programa
y le pongo entonces sobre la mesa el
mismo punto de partida con que le puse a
manolo yes desde su perspectiva panorama
general del legado de lo que dejaba
mijail gorbachov lo positivo y lo
negativo
bueno el legado o la parte positiva es
muy superior a los elementos que puedan
considerarse negativos lo primero es que
la derrota política final de gorbachov y
ahora su fallecimiento es un golpe muy
duro para los sectores democráticos que
en rusia están conociendo una de sus
horas más negras
en claudio continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda a la inversa estábamos
conversando con manolo sobre los
conceptos de libertad y democracia que
fueron parte de ese legado que deja
mijail gorbachov y que dan valores que
no eran no estaban presentes en la
entonces unión soviética
a mí me llama la atención el concepto
que él tenía de esa sociedad que debería
cambiar claudio y él le daba una mayor
prioridad al individuo al ciudadano
soviético de darle precisamente libertad
esbozó una capacidad de actuar por
encima del estado soviético que era
también completamente contrario a las
reglas o a lo que había instaurado este
sistema en la unión soviética éste fue
parte de
desencadenar ese esa fractura dentro del
partido dentro de la sociedad y bueno en
las consecuencias que trajo hoy en día
una prioridad del ciudadano del
individuo por encima del estado
bueno es cierto
gorbachov por un lado es subir a la
centena del socialismo
en que le entendía como un
ensanchamiento del liberalismo político
en dirección social o sea el régimen
comunista ha desalentado la había
despolitizado a los individuos a la
población había desinterés a la de la
economía
el régimen iba derecho al muro iba
derecho al colapso y gorbachov era uno
de los pocos dirigentes del país que
entendió que había que enfrentar ese
tipo de
coyuntural si no era sistémica y
efectivamente como usted dice
restaurar
iniciativas sana
dentro de lo que él pensaba cómo hacer
las rectas de distribución de la riqueza
y en eso pensaba que
los individuos tenían que los activos de
la política
manolo retomar la conexión con usted le
pregunto por esa serie de cambios que él
plantea usted mencionaba que uno de
estos propósitos que él tenía era
precisamente mantener la unión soviética
conformada con la 15 con las 15
repúblicas pero también había cierto
malestar en algunas de las repúblicas y
comenzaba a ver estos pequeños
estallidos de nacionalismo sobre todo en
los tres estados bálticos y en algunos
países en el cáucaso esto también fue un
fallo de la lectura de el entender que
había países que no se sentían
identificados con este modelo comunista
y sobre todo por la forma como habían
sido incorporados a la unión habló
específicamente de esos tres estados
bálticos estonia letonia y lituania
bueno mírate santiago a que hay algo
bien interesante mencionado y tiene que
ver con esos tres estados que mencionan
la incorporación de ellos yo nunca se
sintieron cómodos porque porque ellos
siempre fueron europeos lo mismo pasó
con ucrania ucrania siempre se sintió
europea dentro de la unión soviética
aparte cuál es el problema cuál es el
origen del problema en ucrania para que
lo entendamos es que cuando los rusos
comandan la unión soviética cuando los
rusos comandan la unión soviética y cada
uno de los directores del partido
comunista cada uno los secretarios del
partido comunista de cada una de las
repúblicas hay países en esas repúblicas
estaba siempre de segundo al mando un
ruso o sea los rusos tenían a todos los
rusos en todas las demás catorce
repúblicas dirigiendo y mandando aparte
de eso la forma como lo hacían eran
prácticamente segundos pero en la
espalda pero realmente estaban mandando
como mandaban era la gran pregunta del
millón estos países siempre se sintieron
humillados ante los dictados de moscú
nunca se sintieron cómodos porque lo que
se sentía avasallados los socios en
propiedad este era el gran problema que
tenían ellos y en lo cual se sentían a
ello les impusieron usted los del re
báltico producen buenas leyes tienen
buen ganado vacuno bovino ustedes van a
producir dulces y demás cosas y leche y
todo lo que necesita la unión soviética
usted de sucre área no tienen buenos
campos vamos a producir campo para lo
mismo bien diga usted tienen buenos
cerebros ucr abiertos vamos a ponerlos
en los laboratorios mejores para
producir armas nucleares y demás aquí
las mejores máquinas y aviones lo van a
hacer ustedes entonces esto le molestó
muchísimo a las repúblicas la forma
tanto así tanto así que ucrania por
ejemplo tuvo una colectivización del
campo amarga y triste y que terminó en
una hambruna porque stalin le cambió el
sistema de producción porque ellos no se
adaptaron nunca a la unión soviética a
esto de la colectivización del campo y
por eso fueron llamados varias dentro de
la unión soviética
las cosas como tú ves no era cómodo y
por esto piensa en la república cuando
se les dio la oportunidad cuando mijaíl
gorbachov esboza esto de la libertad y
la democracia muchos entendieron que la
la gran oportunidad va bien de disolver
toda esta historia llamada unión
soviética saudí en esto lo que nos deja
ver entonces es que pese a este intento
de mantener una sociedad igualitaria de
tener
cero preferencias dentro de los quince
estados integrantes de la unión
soviética sí se notaba algunas
diferencias entre las repúblicas y esto
generaba cierta inconformidad e
incomodidad había países mucho más
desarrollados en términos industriales
habló por ejemplo de ucrania o belarús o
incluso los tres estados bálticos si lo
comparamos por ejemplo con armenia o con
azerbaiyán que tenía industria petrolera
o con netaji quixtán que es un país
sumamente rural y montañoso y al día de
hoy sigue siendo un país con bastantes
dificultades económicas estas
diferencias económicas dentro de las
repúblicas también ya está generando
grietas al interior de la urss
pero
no
usarla en la misma palabra este
[Música]
podemos diferenciar algo hay algunos
entes
que habían sido incorporados
conquistados colonizados ya en la época
zarista todo es culpa de la unión
soviética al avión soviético nn da una
serie de regiones que habían sido
incorporadas por el zarismo cuando dio
incorporada me refiero al colonialismo
efectivamente la centralización extrema
del poder político y económico la
planificación hasta los últimos detalles
de la economía y la
[Música]
esa superioridad rusa que se manifestaba
a través del número dos de cada
república como lo recordaba manolo o por
por ejemplo el hecho de que en ucrania
en la universidad había que en ruso y no
en ucraniano etcétera etcétera bueno
todo eso en este
digamos que hacía nacer un malestar
evidente
malestar que por probable que recordar
estaba equilibrado
otras otros factores porque la
revolución de octubre las compara a
todos esos países un ascensor social
formidable
alfabetizó e instaló economías
industriales
digamos que había toda una masa
campesina que había vivido en la
servidumbre hasta mil 861 que fue manzi
para luego sin las tierras el poder
soviético cuando hizo la revolución lo
primero que hizo lenin fue firmar el
decreto de la paz que era demandada por
toda la población y el segundo fue
entregar la tierra a los campesinos
eso creó una base social para el régimen
el problema es que el régimen agotó sus
posibilidades de ascensor social en los
años 60 en ciencias sociales claras
nosotros lo usamos para decir el ascenso
del bienestar de las masas populares no
atravesó ya a mediados de los 60 no
funcionaba más si no funcionaba más por
un lado por la dictadura política la
falta total de libertades de opinión de
prensa de religión etcétera y por el
otro lado por una economía severamente
mente
manejada desde el centro con el caos que
seguía porque las burocracias y las
élites de cada región cómo hacían para
enriquecerse tenían que falsificar los
datos entonces
yo recuerdo porque estábamos en esos
años
corbacho se le pregunta
máxima autoridad en sociología de la
unión soviética cuáles son las
realidades económicas necesita nato
necesita estadísticas y está académica
esta señora le dice camarada no le puedo
dar esos datos porque no los tenemos
todo es falso todo es falso había que
cubrir la corrupción
falsificando batos
eso es uno de los grandes problemas que
enfrentó gorbachov y el otro problema
bueno la resistencia de los sectores
conservadores y del complejo militar o
industrial
claro justamente para allá iba la
pregunta que le quería hacer a manolo
sobre cuál podría haber sido el error de
cálculo de gorbachov en estas reformas
en este plan tan ambicioso si fue
precisamente no contar dentro de este
plan con la línea más dura o
conservadora del partido y también nos
sobra decir la línea más privilegiada
dentro de esta sociedad soviética a la
hora de proponer estas reformas tal vez
esto fue lo que le jugó en contra como
lo ve usted manolo
mira santiago hay que entender algo muy
lógico y muy sencillo primero lo
perfilaban y nos explicaba que fue
preparado para todo esta historia
es por lo recio por el carácter que
tenía yo lo trate te dije en dos
oportunidades
conversamos ampliamente de lo divino en
lo humano pero notaba en el que la
región lo que te hablaba y lo con la
forma como te habla o sea muy amable muy
querido el anciano pero era una persona
bien complicada que te quiere decir esto
él sabía cuando el 85 en abril en el
pleno del partido
esbozaba este proyecto sabía que iba a
chocar contra una élite la élite más
privilegiada de la sociedad y también
sabía que iba a encontrar en los
obstáculos de ellos y que podrían ellos
eventualmente sacarlos del poder como se
supo y las teorías cooperativas de cómo
murieron los anteriores a él que no
duraron mucho tiempo y el poder eso lo
sabía el absolutamente pero él tenía que
apuntalar todo eso no olvides que el
golpe de estado es la culminación de
todas las teorías conspirativas en
contra de mi genio y corbacho y en
contra de todo lo que buscaba y quería
en la unión soviética pero está
absolutamente claro lo que pensaba lo
que
y era que esta élite privilegiada
tendría que desaparecer de alguna manera
y fíjate tú aparece una figura de sanz
de yekaterimburgo el señor bolivia él se
aparece moscú y se convierte en un
enemigo jurado de
gorbachov y él era una de las personas
que estaban en contra de los procesos
como lo planteaba gorbachov corbacho
planteaba el cambio de la unión
soviética pero no así drásticamente ni
de esa manera de acabar la unión
soviética de la noche a la mañana
renuncia a todo esto y permite el fin de
la unión soviética porque él tenía una
alternativa o sea acá me lo están
sacando a los tanques para reprimir para
masacrar al pueblo y seguir con la
historia eran soviética o simplemente
permitía que esto pasaba y prefirió lo
otro incluso hasta su propia muerte
cuando fue allí confinado incrimina en
ese famoso golpe de estado y cuando
aparecieron estos señores en la sala yo
estaba allí como uno de los periodistas
e internacionales cuando dijeron mi
amigo o mijail gorbachov se retira del
poder no puede seguir porque está
enfermo pues toda esta historia cuando
uno ve aquello y si no pero qué pasa qué
es lo que está pasando aquí con mijail
gorbachov y es cuando tú entiendes que
esto es un golpe de estado y que ellos
eran los que tenía justamente mira el
rollo que antes cortarlo en la cabeza
para seguir adelante y los cambios y
ellos se lo impidieron enormemente
escribió uno de los obstáculos grandes
que él tuvo para sus reformas fueron
estos señores se necesitaban una figura
sobre la que recaerá todos los
señalamientos por los hechos que estaban
aconteciendo y pin claudio esto tal vez
es una de las preguntas que más se hace
uno cuando lee la historia de la
biografía de mijail gorbachov y es la
perspectiva que hay de él en occidente y
la perspectiva que hay de él en rusia
precisamente por los hechos que
transcurrieron allí y esas dificultades
económicas y políticas que hubo una vez
colapsó la unión soviética porque ésta
diferencia porque los rusos no pueden
entender
desde la misma perspectiva que lo vemos
en occidente donde se le ve incluso
hasta un premio nobel se le dio por
haber apostado por la cercanía entre el
mundo occidental y la unión soviética y
por apagar la guerra fría
bueno me parece que en occidente es un
respiro en los años 80 fueron los años
la segunda mitad de los 80 para ser más
precisos donde empezamos a pensar que
bueno se terminaba la guerra fría que la
paz se estaba asegurando que podía haber
un desarme nuclear el futuro aparecía
esclarecido o lindo ni la caída del muro
vino a coronar ese optimismo en la
visión del interior es diferente porque
las reformas no traen inmediatamente un
progreso o bienestar hay dos tipos de
reformas están las reformas políticas
que fueron aprobadas por la inmensa
mayoría la liberación de los presos
políticos
la eliminación de la censura una
multiplicidad de candidaturas políticas
etcétera las reformas económicas son más
difíciles de
de transitar los resultados llegan más
tarde y a esto se suma una cierta
un acierto un cierto hábito muy
importante la unión soviética
era la patria común para mucha gente
para una gran cantidad de los pueblos
soviéticos y del pueblo ruso en
particular que se sentía el hermano
mayor de
la guerra había había afianzado y
consolidado eso el lazo no hay que
olvidarlo entonces
cuando hay caos cuando hay descontento
tiene que concentrarse en alguna persona
y bueno
muchas veces
sabemos que los dirigentes pueden tener
buenas intenciones y cuando hay
problemas se revierte la la reglas o
fuerza no si eso pasa no solamente en la
unión soviética sino también en américa
latina manolo pasó a preguntarle un poco
por el escenario actual lo que estamos
viendo de la rusia actual es un
escenario completamente opuesto a ese
deseo que tenía mijail gorbachov de una
unión soviética o de una rusia dentro de
la unión soviética con muchas más
libertades en cómo analizar lo que está
sucediendo con este país en este momento
y ese legado que estaba tratando de
dejar y mijail gorbachov en ese momento
bueno me dicen que perdimos la conexión
con manolo vamos a retomar la entonces
le trasladó la pregunta a claudio que es
nuestro otro invitado en la ciudad de
buenos aires sobre lo que está
sucediendo en rusia en este momento
usted mencionaba que están o no en uno
de los momentos más oscuros de su
historia como entender entonces que se
está devolviendo este país en el tiempo
está volviendo a escenarios justamente
de la antigua unión soviética
y más atrás todavía de russian fíjese
que 4 día el presidente del consejo
constitucional de la federación de rusia
máxima autoridad del asuntos legales
escribió un artículo
de la guerra sobre contra ucrania donde
lamenta la emancipación de la
servidumbre de mil 861 porque dice que
cuando el campesinado estaba en la
servidumbre bueno tenía conflictos con
los propietarios de
este de las tierras pero al ser liberado
de esos propietarios se volcaron contra
el gobierno y él plantea que la
servidumbre puede ser un lazo del pueblo
y el poder esto es lo que esto es parte
de los valores que el pse en kunming nos
ofrece a nosotros
a esto se le asocia que
el kremlin piensa ni en términos de
fidelidad a la historia rusa y al estado
ruso
o sea la fidelidad a la tradición
zarista a la tradición imperial y en ese
sentido la
disolución de la unión sobre mi vida por
ello es una tragedia porque ya no son
dicen la gran potencia que fue la unión
soviética cuál es el objetivo no es
ucrania ucrania
es un daño colateral lo que ellos
plantean es que rusia tiene que ser de
nuevo será gran pop y en particular la
potencia hegemónica que reemplace a los
eeuu
en ese orden de ideas claudio lo que no
puede analizar es que ambos personajes
tanto putin como gorbachov
la apuesta en un cambio le apostaron en
su momento un cambio precisamente para
provocar o buscar un nuevo orden mundial
como cómo se puede analizar ese
escenario actual cuál es ese orden
mundial que está buscando putin habiendo
dejado todo este legado que llevaba a
rusia
y en transición hacia la democracia una
economía de mercado y poco a poco
escalando nuevamente para hacer un país
líder a nivel internacional
desde hace una veintena de años por lo
menos el mundo es multilateral en el
sentido de la dirección en los años 90
bosch ruso hizo que los estados unidos
fuesen realmente la única potencia que
dirigía eso se relativismo mucho a
partir de principios de este siglo
nosotros sabemos hoy que no se pueden
resolver los problemas internacionales y
la presencia rusa fíjese lo que pasó en
siria por ejemplo donde los rusos fueron
al dictador sirio y el tercer
participante en esto es china entonces
no es que hoy los eeuu
pueden no lo que quieren es un mundo
multipolar
cambiar el orden del mundo significa
para los rusos
no para los rusos en general para putin
hizo y su camarilla
significa reemplazar a occidente
una alianza con china
la perspectiva de claudio le hago la
misma pregunta manolo las impresiones
que tiene sobre este punto de quiebre en
el orden mundial que le apostaban tanto
putin como gorbachov en sus diferentes
épocas como entender ese orden mundial
de hoy en día propuesto por putin a
través de los actos que estamos viendo
en los últimos meses en ucrania y en
diferentes escenarios internacionales
que deja de lado todo lo que trató de
buscar el colapso de la unión soviética
miraría y luego que hay que entender muy
interesante cuando mijaíl gorbachov le
dice a el señor reagan vamos a destruir
las armas en reikiavik fue famosa esa
cinta vamos a destruir las armas pasivas
vamos a destruir las armas nucleares de
los estados unidos el audio soviética se
abre una perspectiva y como decía el
colega desde argentina muy claro se
entendía que el mundo en ese momento
comenzaba a dormir más tranquilo y
respiraba para tranquilo porque una
hecatombre ya no sobre vendría a después
a esto de la guerra fría en ese momento
mijail gorbachov centavo la base grande
para decir queremos integrarnos al mundo
queremos la paz y obviamente queremos la
colaboración y la hermandad entre todos
exactamente nos trataba de un mundo
unipolar ni multipolar el que acuñó esta
palabra de mundo multipolar fue morís y
el ser cuando en uno de sus arranques de
borrachera y locura se fue a china y
allí justamente con
y penn y demás y toda esta camarilla
china les dijo el mundo necesita no un
poder unibe unipolar sino multipolar
allí comienza entonces putin también a
ver y entender el mundo necesita un
contrapeso porque estamos decía el
colega no existiese con tropezó en ese
momento cuando la unión soviética se
acaba existe una especie de vacío en el
mundo entonces viene
putin y entiende absolutamente todo esto
y comienza lentamente a labrar un
destino de rusia hacia europa a proponer
un string uno a proponer un string 2 a
venderles gas a venderse como el gran
socio fiable para el resto de la vida y
se les muestra que les dio a vender gran
al resto de la vida y se europa
administrador de bienes y servicios a
rusia lo que estaba haciendo
atendiendo una cama para precisamente
ceder los puntales al fas una cabra
australia y éste quiere decir a la
vuelta de la esquina crear un nuevo
orden mundial teniendo a europa a los
pies arrodillada porque quieras tú no
quieras santiago si está arrodillada
esta rodilla van de putin porque porque
el petróleo y el gas todavía se necesita
en europa que vaya fluyendo formaron los
otros usos eso es realmente lo que
pensaba crear un nuevo orden mundial con
irán con china con ella con los imanes y
el icloud yo manolo se me acaba el
tiempo este tema no ha sonado para dos
programas para analizar los diferentes
temas relacionados con la vida de mijail
gorbachov yo les agradezco haber estado
con nosotros haber hecho este análisis y
haber expuesto sus teorías sobre el
papel que jugó este político a lo largo
del siglo 21 gracias por haber estado
con nosotros y ustedes también gracias
por su sintonía sigan con france24
[Música]